i'm going to talk to you today about
what cyber security can teach us about
testing for kobe 19.
this work was done in collaboration with
dr phil cohen for coast ai
and it's a part of my thesis work for
phd
so imagine that you're a doctor and you
have a waiting room
filled with patience and you only have
one swab left
who would you test for covert 19
this question is relevant and asked here
because testing is bounded
it's bounded by the number of variable
tests bounded by reagan
bottlenecks and for many other technical
domains
let me ask you again if you were a
doctor and those were your patients
who would you test for copy 19.
on the right uh upper corner we have a
patient that is 70s
he's suffering from diarrhea and from
cold and he has a cold
if he has copper 19 early detection
could mean
that we are going to treat him not
better and we are going to improve his
survival rates
on the bottom right corner we have a
patient at his 30s he has high fever
he's coughing and he's suffering from
body
from muscle legs so he's he has a high
probability of testing positive for kobe
19.
early detection of him or positive
test result means that we can start the
contact tracing and we can trace all the
people that he has been in contact
with recently and maybe stop the
spreading of the virus
so our answer to this question depends
on our priorities
on what we would like to achieve by
testing for the
testing for kobe 19. so why
are we testing for kobe 19 we are
testing for copy 19 because we would
like to identify sick individuals in
order to treat them
correctly and safely we also would like
to stop the disease from spreading
by contact tracing of positive
individuals but we also have a third
goal we would like to provide accurate
data for government decision making
for example the government would like to
know
if there is a need for a lockdown or
maybe if we're
already in a lockdown can we get out of
our lockdown
how fast can we lock to get out of the
lockdown etc
so
um we did this uh research during april
when israel was at the peak of her her
first wave of cobit 19
and at that time there was there was
little known about
how the virus behaves how the virus
spread
and and you know
each country had a different testing
policy most of them were unofficial so
it was really hard
to compare between countries what is the
situation
and there were huge differences as i
said because
italy for example tested only people
that were in hospitals
and sweden tested the worst cases and
all the dead people
and in israel we had we tested with the
policy we had to have
a few symptoms or to be in contact with
the
confirmed case and we also had some
exploration
and in juhan they were planning on
testing everyone that is 11 million
people
so the testing policy can really differ
between these
countries
most of these countries we're not
talking about one who had no limitations
had a um restricted capacity of tests so
they had
implemented the risk-driven policy the
problem with the risk-driven policy is
that the result
is very biased towards the policy that
is
if we're testing only people with
symptoms then we're most likely not to
see patients that are asymptomatic
and the policy can also really determine
the results
because if when at the beginning at
april when they were testing only
hospitals it make it look ten times as
deadly as it
is this bias has two major problems the
first one is that the decision makers
they don't get
accurate and wide information that they
need for decision making
and also we are missing our ability to
identify
of early identification of clusters of
new clusters
because we are busy on testing what we
already know that is
more likely to be positive
this phenomena of being trapped in a
subspace of
options and thereby losing our ability
to explore
beyond what we already know is very well
known in recommender systems
like in netflix when you're if you're
watching two days in a row
the christmas movie then at the third
day you're more likely to get
all of your feed filled with christmas
movies sorry netflix i really like you
this phenomena is called the filter
bubble
and we really need to know that this is
our we have this problem
in order to deal with it
so what i'm talking about today the
problem that we can't really test all
the people all the population and we
only miss
we can only look at a sample is a
sampling problem
but why are we testing what would we
like to achieve
we would like to discover as many
positive cases if not all of them
for treatment and for contact tracing as
we discussed before
but we would also want uh want to learn
about the nature of the spread of the
virus
is the sample group representative
enough just like in the elections
so we have two goals and we have to keep
it in mind
in order to do our sampling right this
challenge of monitoring the population
with the limited capacity
is not unique for epidemiology and it's
actually applied in many many domains
since this is a problem of balancing
exploitation
the need to maximize the detection of
many if not all infected people
with exploration they need to learn more
about the nature of the spirit
then a mob is a perfect fit it's like
really natural that it comes to mind
i originally done my phd work started my
phd work in the domain of the cyber
security monitoring
and especially in monitoring database
activity monitoring
so what does database activity
monitoring looks like
we have hundreds of thousands of
transactions
per second hundreds of thousands of
transaction per second that going
through the system
we cannot really save them all because
it's a huge amount of data so instead
we are logging only a subset of the data
and this data that is log themselves
is fed into the anomaly detection system
which our goal is to detect the risks
and the the risk events
what is the logging policy since we
can't save all the transaction as i told
you
we are only saving a fraction which
fraction should we say
well that is decided by the regulation
telling us what data should be tested
saved in and for how long and by the
security officer that defines the
hazards and the risk in this
in the domain and how is it done it's
done manually um
it's a manual job there so it's
basically
rule-based uh scenario or policy the
policies
basically will be what are the
problems with the in the cyber security
domain
the pro the problem is and not only in
the cyber security domain it's also
very similar in our problem problems is
that the policy shifts
what it captures therefore creating a
filter bubble
and since we're only capturing the risky
activity
therefore the security officer doesn't
really know what the normal activity
looks like so our data is really biased
and skewed
um for example in the kobe 19 problem
the initial estimate of kobe 19
mortality were really skewed and
really high because we are testing only
people in hospitals and only dead bodies
and since we are
so skewed and we are trapped in a filter
bubble then it's really hard to identify
new types of risk
or in the copy 19 problem new clusters
so i would like to move to make a shift
from a static policy to a dynamic policy
that really
learns the material and keeps searching
for new
um risk and learning how things should
what to monitor
so why are cyber security risk
monitoring and copy 19 testing similar
because in both problems we have a
capacity that is limited
and in both problems the individuals and
the features can change their risk
profile during their life cycle
so the probability of me testing
positive for coordinating today
may change drastically if the people in
my area are
um infected with kobe 19 than it was
five weeks ago when there were no
infections around me
and this are both problems monitoring
had two similar goals we would like to
maximize the detected infected
individuals
and we would like to maximize the
knowledge about the spread of the
for decision me
so now that we define the problem in
terms of exploration and exploitation
it's only natural that we seek for a
solution in the
set of problems that are called
multi-armed bandits
for those of you who are unfamiliar with
it um let me tell you a little bit about
it so
this is a set of problems that come from
the domain of uh
playing the slot machine so imagine that
you were in the room of the slot machine
in las vegas
and you have a bucket of coins in your
hand and you have to decide which
machine to play so
um if you're just sitting at the first
machine that you
found in the room then maybe there is a
better machine or
many other better machines in the room
that you're not playing with but if you
keep hopping
between machines then maybe your miss
someone else is winning at this time
at the machine with a really high reward
that you found before so this need to
balance
between exploration and exploitation is
well explode
explored within this problem
and there are very good solution for
this problem
that are proposed
so how is it relevant to our
problem and how is it implemented
as i said before in the database
activity monitoring our goal was to find
the optimal strategy for sampling users
uh in the data in the database
activity and using the available
resources in order to maximize the
monitored risky activity
so um this is a sub
problem a new problem the real problem
that we define
within the domain of museum present
where we have
a capacity at each time frame instead of
playing only one slot machine
we're pulling a few arms how many arms
depend on
our available resources and also
in the slot machine there the reward
probability is static but in
our problem their probability it may
change during the
user's life cycle as i said before the
the probability of the of an individual
to test positive may
change drastically between days and
weeks
depending on the general condition
so i'm taking my inspiration from the
cyber security domain
how is it done in the cyber security
domain how do we implement monitoring
how did i implement monitoring
well i created a risk or per event and i
ranked these events
by in the in the descending order
and investigated the top events why only
the top events because
our capacity is limited i will show you
that we can implement the same approach
for the cover on a virus monitoring
problem
now i will describe how to implement at
the capacity epsilon gradient algorithm
that
i um suggest to solve this problem
so we're working in time frames every
time frame we're
defining the policy for the next at the
beginning of each time when we're
defining the policy
that we'll be implementing during the
time frame at the end of each time frame
we are rethinking and relearning and
so on so at the beginning of the time
frame we would
create a rank for all the candidates
using the risk score
we would sample several things for 70 of
the capacity using the most risky
approach
and we are randomly sampling the rest 30
that is 30 percent of the capacity
after the at the end of the time frame
we would update the risk scoring model
based on the results of the previous
time frames
the excel under the epsilon radio
algorithm stands for the proportion of
the capacity invested in exploration so
in
our case it's 30
so at the beginning of april when i was
working on it was i was just like you
know
cooking this idea in my mind i was
asking myself
well i have this great idea right of
balancing exploration and exploitation
and i really understand all the problems
that
what is wrong with the way that we are
testing today but
this thing that i want to suggest can
can we implement it
for kobe 19 testing
can potential candidates for testing for
copyright can be ranked
who should we test first so to show the
visibility
of my idea um first i have to show that
we have we can rank
all these cases and um
for that we use the data set published
by the
israeli ministry of health data the
testing data set
um if you're interested about the data
set we can talk about it
later and um
you know what we did the data
exploration like any data scientist
would do and we saw that the the contact
with positive patients cough and fever
were a stronger strongest were the
strongest features so
we decided to compare three different um
ranking methods the first one was the
baseline the rule-based one
which um we use these high correlated um
features and we scored them with weights
contact with positive patient got
two points half got one point fever got
one point then
all the candidates got their scores and
were ranked accordingly
we also used the linear spm classifier
and the polynomial
nasblasian classifier it was a
polynomial from the second degree
because
we assumed that there were
relations between two features that
could be learned but we didn't really
want to overfit
the really interesting question is how
to evaluate the result of our
um classifiers so
we're not really interested in
classifying because we only want to rank
the
uh the results so we don't really care
about the general at measure
since we are using the ranking to decide
who to test first and
using their most risky approach what's
important for us is the measure that
is called recall it in because we would
like to know
if our ranking is affecting is effective
given a certain capacity
i would like to present for you the
results so we're comparing
the recall at n for five different
capacity sizes 1 000 to
up to 5 000 um tests
um in general since in israel we during
april we had many
uh technical problems we decided to
normalize
to numerous data and to work in time
frames of weeks so we aggregated the
entire
uh testing of the week and the results
during this week
and um the initial that exploration
showed that we had about
five weeks of data so we used the first
two that
two weeks to learn the model and the
three
following weeks to
predict also i can show you for the for
the winning
um the winning strategy
just to make sure because we didn't
really have that much data
we uh you use bootstrapping to calculate
confidence intervals
so um as we can see at
10 000 um tests
per week we get a recall of
um which is about two percent of the
test during that week we get a recall of
34
positives out of the 34 of the out of
the total positive this week
with 10 of the capacity we already get
66
of the positive during that week and if
we uh elevate the
capacity to 70 of the capacity where we
we are at 92 of the capacity of that
week
so this would this really enable us to
um
allocating a testing capacity for um
exploration without harming the recall
so as i said we can do
both ranking and exploration without
losing
the recall so what does this
framework looks like as i said we're
working in time frames so every time
frame
at every time frame we are ranking
candidates
testing investing most of the capacity
about 70 of it for the top um
top ranked um candidates and
about 30 the capacity for exploration at
the end of the fa
and the time frame we would uh re-uh
evaluate the real use the the collected
data
during this time frame and the previous
timeframes to relearn
the ranking model and to evaluate
our exploration if we have areas that
were neglected like
cities or demographies then we can set
them as a goal for exploration
for random testing in these areas that
were
unexplored recently and um as you can
see all the
people here the little the iphone of the
little people is
where the um expert the main experts are
involved so we are keeping them in the
loop and
they are using the system but they are
also driving the system
and making it work and so as a
and there is a in the initial stage of
building the ranking model
um which is really um
using the domain uh that's the main
expert knowledge
at the beginning and also and when we
also aim to you know to
improve it as we go along but this uh
ranking model it can be plug and play
and we can
plug any ranking model if a better one
is suggested just like
this one here or recently in israel
clelit healthcare
suggested the new ranking model which
sounds really cool
so any ranking model could be applied
here
to rank the candidates
how do we implement exploration we can
implement expression in many
in many ways we can do random testing in
cities regions of population
we can test the medical staff we can
test the
test patients from you know
healthy people from infected racial
regions
we can do random tests in supermarkets
just like we did in israel at the
beginning of the pandemic
um we can test patients with symptoms
that doesn't match the current symptoms
that we know of and also actually today
just today they invented the
most genius where they don't call it
this way but i thought it was genius
they tested all the kindergarten
teachers so
i think it really is a great survey of
the condition in the country
another important thing is that another
important point is that
we tried two models in different time
frames and
training the two more two models um
based on
different time frames and we can see
that there are significant difference in
their effect uh
efficacy so uh what should suggest that
the policy should be updated and and it
really supports the need to
relearn and re-update the ranking model
as we go along
to conclude i redefine the
um setting the policy for coving 19
testing as a sampling problem
and that's just the sampling problem a
sampling problem with the need
to balance between two different goals
the goal of maximizing the detected risk
and detecting all the positive cases
with the goal of building a
representative sample